Yes, ma'am. First of all, we have the ERP login which will be campus.audipay.org.
This is campus.audipay.org.
This is a URL which we share with you so that you can attach it to your homescreen.
Your login will be via phone number and OTP.
If you have a phone number, you can log in via OTP.
If you log in via OTP, you can log in via OTP.
If you have the option to set your password, you can set it on your password.
After opening, our dashboard appears like this.
This will be your company PRT interface.
Your entity's name will be shown here.
This is my ID.
Your name will be created in my ID.
The name of your institute will be created.
After that, we have the top session here.
The session in which you have opened.
The further your distance sessions will be created, the problem will be created.
You can search for sessions.
Now, let's talk about the interface.
For example, we will have separate admission and admission fees.
If you see, all these options are appearing.
This is our permission-based structure.
The student will have the admission interface.
The fee will only have the fee options.
We have a quick link option.
For example, for me, some options are used on a daily basis.
For example, for the fee at week or for the fee clerk, the collect fee option will be used on a daily basis.
You can add a quick link for yourself.
For example, if you add a quick link, the collect fee will come here.
I can directly access the student's fee on daily basis.
This means that this N number of links can be updated according to each user.
This is how your interface will be.
Now, let me show you how we have set up the fee.
The collect fee is at the top.
From here, you can only collect.
From the collect fee option, you have the collect fee online option.
You can also add the online fee separately.
Otherwise, you can also collect from the collect fee online option.
You can also collect from the first option.
This is how you have two or three different options.
You can also collect from the collect fee online option.
You can also add this to the online fee.
We have added a student after testing.
You can search the student's name.
You can also search the student's registration number.
You can also search the student's father name, phone number, etc.
You can search the student from the various options.
You will search the student and the student will appear.
Some details will be shown on the interface.
You can verify the student.
You will click on this.
From here, the student's fee collection section will be opened.
Here, the student's personal details are there.
Then, what is the fee demand?
I have added the student to Paytech Civil.
We have added the total fee of the student in the first year.
We have added a fresh application.
They have taken a fresh application for a literal entry.
There is a goal.
If the student is in the second year or third year, you will have only one student.
We have added a fresh application and a literal entry.
Here, the total fee is coming.
If you ask the student for a concession, they will get a concession.
After concession, the student's payable account will come to you.
The student has received the payment.
Then, the balance of the money will come.
From here, they can redirect the student to concession.
You can click on this and make a concession.
We have not made a concession group yet.
Share your concession groups.
50% of the criteria is concession.
You can also make a movie like this.
Okay.
Send me the criteria.
You can send your fee structure.
We will put a concession criteria in the setup.
If the student has a concession, it will be imported.
If you want to add a new student, I will tell you.
We will add a copy.
Anjali, add the concession.
Okay.
First of all, we have put a due demand.
Here, you have 4 installments.
By default, your first installment will come.
The date you have given will be automatically selected according to the date.
If the due date is the second installment, it will be automatically selected in the second installment.
If you select all, then all the installments will be selected.
Here, all the installments have been selected.
The student's total payable is the total amount.
This is the overall fee.
We have made this according to the case installment fee.
If you think there will be any changes, then this will be the case.
Ma'am, it is possible that our amount will change.
That is possible, ma'am.
I meant the interface.
You have made it that we will take this much in August, then in November, then in February.
Okay.
This is okay.
You take it like this in August, November, May.
There is one more option in this.
It is possible that the student's fee is this.
I will select all the installments.
For example, you have to take one installment, but the student does not pay that much.
You have to enter the amount according to yourself.
There is one option.
You can enter the amount directly here.
For example, the student will pay 10,000 now.
You will enter according to yourself.
The first fee head will get the 10,000.
He will take all the fees from that.
In case you feel that you have to buy according to yourself, you can do that too.
Your cycle is here.
You can buy according to yourself.
You have to take 2,000 in this.
You have to take 1,000 in this.
You are buying according to yourself.
Excuse me, ma'am.
By default, you are saying that the fees in the tuition fee, what will the tuition fee catch first?
Will the tuition fee catch first or something else?
Sir, this is the sequence of head.
This is the first tuition fee.
You can do the head sequence according to yourself.
Okay, okay.
Because we also have the tuition fee in this.
So, first the tuition fee, then the security, then the tuition fee.
First, our security.
Yes, please tell me the head sequence.
I will note it down.
The security will come first, right?
Yes, first the security, then the tuition fee.
Then the transport and also.
First, the security will be there, then the tuition fee.
Then the transport and the hostel will be there.
So, all these will be there after that?
Yes, exactly.
Transport and hostel.
If someone has both transport and hostel, then transport and hostel will be there.
No, no, transport and hostel cannot be there.
Okay, both will be there.
Yes, both will be there.
Transport and hostel.
After that, I think...
All the fines and recharges should be there.
Before the fines, all the fees should be there.
Student funds, corpus funds, other things.
Fine should be there.
Fine can also be calculated according to the date.
I will tell you that too.
After this, all the student development funds will come.
Student funds, then development funds.
First the development funds, then the student funds.
Whatever you have written.
Okay, first the development funds, then the student funds.
Okay, so this is the sequence and contribution.
So according to that, the sequence will be there.
When you collect the rest, you have to show here.
In case, if we are taking it by editing, then it will show here.
How much was the pay and how much you are taking from it.
So, you should know this too.
I will show you a transition of one rupees.
Just to test.
You will stay like this.
Then you have to proceed on it.
After proceeding, it will show you how much you are taking from it.
You have the payment mode.
You are getting cash, cheque and all.
By default, cash is selected.
Now you have to check according to your payment.
Now it's a payment gate.
We have integrated the razor picker on it.
Should we do the razor picker on this too?
So, is it different in this?
No, it stays the same.
I haven't done the fee yet.
They need confirmation.
So, we have done the same on this too.
So, you will feel comfortable only if both have the razor picker.
Yes, that is not an issue.
We need a confirmation.
What happens in that, you select online.
You just have to select online fee.
It will directly integrate you.
You will get the scanner and all.
I don't understand. What did you say?
Yes, you have two options.
One is to collect online fee and the other is to collect normal fee.
In this, you are collecting normal fee in cash and then collecting.
I will show you now.
In this case, you feel that you have been getting online from the beginning.
There are some back gate entries.
You have to check in some other way.
And you have to collect that by entering online.
So, this is that case.
Your institute banks will be made here.
Whatever you tell, the whole institute banks will get it.
They will come to you to select.
You have to give the reference number corresponding to it.
You have to select a particular date.
These are all optional.
Then these remarks are there.
You have to enter some particular fees that you are collecting.
The fee receipt is also saved.
So, these remarks are optional.
This will be the collective one.
You can basically use all these options for collecting.
Now, in case you will directly collect online from ERP.
For example, you have given the scanner in front of you.
Or you have given a card or debit card online.
If you are giving a payment like this.
So, in that case, you have to select online.
Collect online.
So, here it will redirect you to the payment gate.
Now the payment gate is not signed.
So, no payment gate is signed.
The scanner will come there.
It will be scanned and paid.
Now, I will give you a transaction in cash.
So, some kids...
Meenakshi ma'am.
The kids who do it with the scanner.
Which category will they go to?
The ones who come later.
They do it with the scanner.
That we did it from home and all that.
Yes, they do it through the app.
Will they collect online?
Or will they come in the collective?
If the kids don't do it through the app.
They can't do it in Meenakshi ma'am.
No, no, not through the app ma'am.
For example, the kids who do it with the scanner.
They share it with their friends.
Now, they have the one in the back.
They put it in the house.
They only have a screenshot.
And sometimes they bring it after 10 days.
Or after 5 days.
It will come in the collective.
Yes, in the collective.
Okay.
Now, let's do one transaction.
For 1 rupee.
We will do it in cash.
As soon as you collect,
they will give you the confirmation.
You can still cancel it.
So, you will have the confirmation
that you are receiving the amount of this date.
If you say okay,
they will receive your transaction.
And this is a format.
We have set it according to the office.
You can set it according to your office.
This is the format of the receipt.
Please share a logo with us.
Okay.
I think we have done it with you.
Yes.
We have also shared the logo
of the form you gave.
That goes up.
It doesn't come to us.
It is better if you share it in the group.
Then I will integrate it in the app.
It goes to the document.
That is why.
Documents don't come to us.
This is the template of the receipt.
You can see it here.
You can change it according to it.
It comes as a free head
and installs it.
It is customized.
If you want to design it according to you,
it will be done.
Otherwise, it will be recorded.
Okay.
This is the receipt.
It will be recorded according to
how much you collected.
Whatever remark you enter,
it will be displayed.
Will there be a fine head?
Yes. I will tell you the criteria.
I will tell you how it works.
We set up a fine.
For example,
this is from August to October.
It is a three-month fee.
How does it work?
What is the percentage of the fee?
That will be your criteria.
For example, if the last fee is on the 10th,
then on the 11th, it costs Rs.500.
And every October 15 days,
Rs.500 is added.
Okay.
Your last 10th of every month
will cost Rs.500.
Yes.
10th of August,
10th of November,
like this.
Okay.
So, your 10th of August
will cost Rs.500.
Okay.
We will set the last date.
For example, on the 11th of August,
Rs.500 will cost Rs.500.
10th of August.
This is how it will be set.
It will be a fine config.
What are you saying?
From 11th,
what is the percentage?
Rs.500 for every day.
No, not every day.
After 15 days,
Rs.500 is added.
Okay.
After 15 days, Rs.500 is added.
We may set up first.
After the last fee date,
Rs.500.
And after every 15 days,
they will increase by Rs.500.
Okay.
Rs.500 in the last day
and Rs.500 after every 15 days.
Yes.
Okay, sir.
I will tell you how it will work.
We have set it up.
After that, like you collect fees,
at the time of the collect fee,
you have a date here.
By default, it is today's current date.
Now, for example,
your 10th of August is 11th of August.
By default, if you are
on 11th August,
you get a fine at the end.
Calculated fine is shown at the end.
Ma'am, if we have to
pay Rs.40 after the last date,
and it increases by Rs.40 every day,
is that also possible?
Yes.
Ma'am, you have to tell us
which criteria you have to use.
Okay.
First, we had Rs.40,
and then when we were using
software before this,
we had done Rs.500.
We will tell you about that
once we confirm it.
You can easily confirm the fine.
How does the fine work?
If we set the fine,
then it will be applicable
to every course and every student.
Yes.
It will be according to that.
This is the interface.
Have you made a concession
for a new student?
Yes, ma'am.
For example,
if a new student has a fresh application,
you have to sign the concession.
You have an option here.
You can click here and
sign the concession.
Okay.
Anjali, please share the screen.
Anjali, you have to tell us
about the concession, right?
Yes.
Anjali, can you hear me?
Yes, Anjali, I can hear you.
What do I have to tell you, ma'am?
Tell us about the concession
and how to sign it.
Ma'am,
we have to select
a concession here.
We will make different heads
according to the concession data.
I have made a manual one.
Click on the manual and
sign it.
After signing, we will set
the amount here.
Either 10% or 1000.
It will be set according to
the amount you give.
Then we will set
It will be set according to
the concession.
After that, we will save it.
One minute, Anjali.
Ma'am, what is the option here?
For example, you have made it according to the percentage.
Do you think that
you have fixed the student
to have a sports concession?
There are different concession groups.
For example, sports concession
and tuition fee is 10%.
Right.
We have a master in the system.
We will define 10% and
only on the tuition fee.
The way you select and sign,
it will automatically calculate according to the fee.
10% will be made.
There is also a manual.
You have to set a fixed amount.
You have the manual in that case.
You have to set the amount according to you.
In that case, the manual works.
Select the concession group.
After that,
come to the bottom, Anjali.
Here, you have to enter the remark.
Why are you giving the concession?
There is a choose file option with it.
Sometimes it happens with principles
or with an application signature.
You have to upload the application document.
This is not mandatory.
Basically, it is optional.
You can upload it according to you.
If you feel that you have to upload a document
in the concession group.
We will save it with the remark.
It will be saved.
Remarks are mandatory.
After you are assigned from here,
you will get the payable below.
You will know how much it is made.
Anjali, close this.
Come down to the bottom.
From here, you can directly collect.
From here, you can also collect fee.
You can also collect the fee.
Collect fee will be in the bottom
and also in the top.
You have a payment history
on a particular student.
The fee transactions are cut.
The payment history shows the receipt
of a single individual student.
From here, you can also collect.
We will put it consistently in this pattern.
It will show automatically
in detail.
Yes, it will show in detail.
What you have shown
is only the concession
or the payment format.
But when we are collecting
the fee, it will show automatically.
Yes, it will show on the receipt.
If we collect after concession,
it will show that
it is the student's concession.
If you show the receipt format,
it will show on the receipt.
Okay.
This data,
the transactions that are made,
there is a transaction list on the top.
From there, you have common transactions.
This is the transaction list.
The daily transaction
will be a list.
On the top, you have Excel.
You can export according to yourself in Excel.
Okay.
And there are more reports.
Back it once, Anjali.
These are your fee reports.
There are multiple reports in this.
Daily fee report, combined daily collection,
all these are according to themselves.
Yes, there is a due fee.
You have to check the due fee.
How many students are there, how much is received,
how much is pending.
If we take out the total
of children's default list,
then we will take it out in due fee, right?
There is an option in due fee.
Anjali, show the filter.
See, you have the templates.
Yes, show the filter.
We will show the filter.
Sir, you will get filters
Basically, you have to see
a particular class.
There is a class, stream and batch.
There is one in this.
Show student with zero dues.
What does this mean?
For example, you have to see that student
whose zero dues are not there.
So, you will do it by saying no.
If everyone pays,
it doesn't mean anything.
Those who have pending only want the same.
If you say yes,
then both the students will come together.
Okay.
We have also given an awake status.
I think you might know about this.
Active students are active in our institute currently.
Awake means
those who have paid
the fees of this session.
In case you want only those students,
defaulted students who have
gone from one time to another
and no one has paid yet,
then we want only that student's list.
So, if you will falsely export data
then only those students will come
who haven't paid a rupee yet for a particular session.
So, these filters...
In this filter,
there is a filter related to the amount
that I have to see students with 10,000
who have paid.
For example, new students come
and I have to say that I have to see
students with 10,000.
So, that can be seen by applying the filter.
No sir, it won't be related to the amount.
Okay.
Amount-wise filter is not there, right?
No sir, it is not amount-wise.
Because in that case,
it won't even be known
because every head has a different amount.
You are saying that only up to 10,000
will be known, right?
Exactly, what happens is that
our registration is from 10,000.
After one time, we need this list
of those who have paid 10,000
because after that
we consider the fees
that we will not consider 10,000
after one time.
That's why I was asking amount-wise.
You are saying that 10,000
will be taken in admission, right?
Yes, yes.
That is different for admission.
You will get that in admission reports.
But there will be no amount-wise filter, right?
No sir, it is not like that.
No problem, I will raise it.
If you want, you can get it.
No, no, no.
Okay, okay.
If you feel that you want it,
then there is no problem.
We will raise it.
We will give a timeline and
we will get that option accordingly.
Okay, sir.
So these are your reports.
We have different sections.
So these are according to your columns.
For example, you need a class, batch,
reg number.
If you don't need a column,
then these are according to your columns.
Okay.
For all this,
when we will work, then it will be up, ma'am.
Exactly, then we will know.
Basically, there are reports like this.
Excel and print work according to that.
So this is the fee.
So you are okay with the demand?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay, sir.
Then please share your student data.
Yes, ma'am.
We will import the student data of old students.
And with the data of old students,
sir, we will also need dues.
There will be old dues pending
for many students who will go ahead.
Okay, yes, yes.
According to that, we will also put those dues.
So how do we put the dues in the previous dues?
How urgent is this that
you are asking for data of students' fees?
See the data of old students,
sir, as soon as we get it,
your collection will start here.
There is nothing else.
No, I am talking to you about this.
Because the last installment
of the year is
May 10, right?
So, most probably,
on the 20th or
the 23rd,
our maximum fee collection
will be here.
You will have the minimum data that we have to take from the students.
The minimum data of the year.
If you fetch that data then,
then I think you
will feel comfortable for this.
There is no issue. That will also work.
I mean,
there will not be 2000 students
whose dues you will have to collect.
They will be 200-400.
Okay, let's do one thing.
Send us the student data.
We will import the student data accordingly.
The dues will take place later.
Done, done, done.
Sir, I want to add one thing.
We will have to raise the dues.
How will the fees be collected without the dues?
No, sir.
So when are we going to start
with the fees?
We will start as soon as the data is done.
We have to receive the money.
But sir, the criteria of the fees
that we are receiving
is so high that I feel
that we will work on it
in speed.
Right now, we have a tuning
from the old software.
We will not be able to do that
as soon as 200-400 students
come to the window daily.
No, sir.
We will not be able to do that.
That is a different thing.
You will take the payment
in the last installment.
But the dues
that we have to raise
from them,
the status of the fees of a student
or the 50,000 fees
of a student,
we will have to insert
that to make the dues.
Yes, we will give that.
Not just the dues,
but the stand.
Yes, the stand.
That is what he is saying.
If you send us a student,
we will import the data.
You will get the yearly fees
But the dues,
don't do the stand.
Don't do that.
Stand, student, fees,
including this.
That is what he is saying.
Absolutely.
Student data,
basically.
And the old student,
is it that the old student
concessions go ahead
or does the concession lapse?
What we give you,
it will go ahead.
It will continue.
So you will give the concession
data as well?
The data of the student.
What we will share,
as long as there is no concession,
what we will do,
that will be the stand.
Till now,
there are no fixed concessions
of the students.
We used to have it only after the concession.
It will start from now.
Because the bifurcation
and development,
it is starting from you.
Okay, I understood.
Okay.
Hostel is the same,
there are four divisions.
The same hostel
comes in four parts.
Transport comes in four parts.
Only the security
is of one time.
It will be better if I get the hostel data.
It will be better.
The hostel data will also be there.
How will you give the hostel data?
Will you give only the fees?
We have the hostel module.
In that also,
like our fees,
the same security is 4000.
For example, if our non-AC
is 65000,
it has a division in four parts.
Okay, I will tell you
how it will be.
You told that it is fee dependent.
You are telling only the fees.
The hostel name,
right, the hostel name,
what is the room, what is the bed,
that division is also structured.
If you want to run it, then you can see.
We will talk about that once.
If you want to give the warden,
it has not been run yet.
But if we get the details of the rooms,
then we will definitely get it fetched.
If it is that one, then that is also not an issue.
That one can also be run.
In fact, in transport,
it will definitely be that in bus number,
children are divided on the time of
transport.
We will need that division.
Yes, transport has an impact.
You can also send the transport data.
Shall we send the sample Excel
according to our transport?
Sample collection means?
Sample means, sir,
we import all the data from Excel.
What is needed for that?
Bus number,
like which pick up points are
included in that bus number.
Means where is that bus?
We do not have that much detail
yet.
We will have to create all this.
Bus wise,
the division of children
has not been done yet.
Okay, then how do you take
the fees from the students?
Only transport is written and
those are amount wise divisions.
Let's see the fees and tell
if it is coming from Faridabad or
Delhi.
Because there are fees divisions.
There are 24,000,
28,000, 32,000,
like this.
So you keep all that in that
or else there are four
installments.
Yes, there are four installments.
But as we are talking about bus
number and this route,
we do not have that division yet.
But we have to get it done, ma'am.
We will provide this, ma'am.
We will provide this data
through transport incharge.
We will provide it through transport
incharge.
and stoppage.
It is simple.
I will share sample excel.
You can share
the particular incharge
and we will prepare it.
The accounts
are also
You can tell us if it is in this forum.
Yes, it is in this forum.
Or we will provide it in our
download format.
You are talking about accounting module?
Yes, the data you need of the student
is in that.
Or we will download
our excel and
mail it to you.
That is more easy.
The data which is already in our software,
we will fetch it ourselves.
That is also better.
The student data will be managed.
There is transport, fees
and we need it
so that we can import it exactly.
The student data is done.
The student's reg number should be unique.
The data you will get
is of transport
and hostel.
And that is accurate.
Just one minute, ma'am.
Our data is in that.
We have an admission number
and a university roll number.
Okay, ma'am.
Both these parts will be included
and it will continue.
We will tell you the series
of the new admissions
which will start from 26.
The registration will be done
from that series.
You told us two numbers.
One is university registration number
and the other is university roll number.
College, university, admission number.
Sorry.
Sir, only admission number
and university roll number.
In the primary case
we have three options.
The admission number is in the primary case.
Yes, admission number.
Because when the student's
roll number is confirmed,
you will get it from the registrar's office.
That will be in the data
that you will share.
That will be the registration number.
Send the student data.
We have also shared a mail.
We have included sample excel
and sent it.
If you want to see.
The mail will be shared with you.
I have the mail ID of you and
Meenakshi ma'am.
Okay.
We have also shared
the document.
We want some modules
to be implemented timely
so that it will be suitable for you
to see and make changes.
Okay.
Update the dates
so that we can expect
the training and all that.
Okay.
I will also share the sample excel
of transport and a hostel
with you.
If you want to run it
you can share both.
The hostel will be set up.
You will get everything.
Thank you.
Ma'am,
just one minute, ma'am.
Let's complete.
The registration form
that you have given.
We have integrated it.
We will see how it will be.
With online payment.
For that, sir,
we thought that
the whole admission team
should have a meeting with them.
Sir, ma'am was saying
that the marketing team
should be involved on Monday.
Sir,
the marketing team
should be involved
when our modules
are completed
and the payment is being received.
As we said,
the online payment
will be received
and it will be forwarded
I have also
filled the test form.
Let's show it once.
Anjali, will you
share the screen of the form
and the ERP?
Tell me how to do it
and how will we get the data on the email?
Sir, Vivek sir,
we have to show them
the marketing.
When our registration is completed,
we will do the training.
After filling the form,
the fees will come to you.
After that, we will do the training.
No, no,
Sir,
are we talking about
our new student?
Sir, the first part of
the new student is
when the fees are received.
But until the data is received,
how will you get the fees?
Sir, you will understand.
We have made the registration form
and given it to them.
We have given the marketing form
but they are not able to get the fees.
First of all, our modules are completed.
That is what we want to say.
Once we get to know
how the director is working
and what he is doing.
The payment is not going.
Please tell us how to show the registration.
Sir, we have
this form.
Anjali, show us the form.
We have put it in a test gate.
It is live.
We have put it in a test gate
so that you can test it according to you.
The day you say live, it will be live.
Live means the actual payment
is going to be deducted.
Now it will be tested.
Anjali, show us the form.
We have this form.
In this form,
there will be your student name,
photo and gender.
Anjali, fill one student form.
We have checked this.
Sir has filled this.
Yes, I have filled this.
I have filled this.
Once you fill this entry,
it will come to your IRP.
If you will do the payment,
then after the payment,
the transaction will come.
Now I will show the transaction.
Anjali, open one entry.
In this, there is a view transaction.
Everything is coming on the left side.
No transaction has been done yet.
You must have filled the over-the-counter form
that you will go to the counter and pay.
Click on the admission screen.
It is coming at the bottom.
It will only increase
when you will receive
the fees of 10,000.
This is according to this.
In case if a student
has done the payment from the form,
then he will show the receipt
in the view transaction.
He will show the receipt here
if you have done the payment from the form.
From online?
Yes.
Anjali,
did we do the email later
or after the survey?
How did you do the survey?
Please show me once.
I did it earlier.
Please show me
the online payment
even if we do the transaction.
Yes, let's do the transaction.
It is posted, it will be done.
Anjali, please fill it.
Should I do it from the sheet?
Yes, do it from here.
Just fill the mandatory details.
Anjali sir's email id,
please tell us your email id.
My email id.
Info at the rate
acm.edu.in
E-D-U
E for elephant.
Is it okay sir?
No, it is not okay.
Now it is okay.
Yes, now it is okay.
Please put a restriction
on the basis of numbers.
Take it up to 12 numbers.
Okay, I will put a restriction
up to 12 digits.
Otherwise the children will get wrong information.
I will note it down.
Restrictions on the hand.
I will provide you
a list of transports.
If he says yes,
the bus stoppage
Okay?
Okay sir, please send it.
Sir, are you in the group?
Yes.
Okay sir, please share it in the group.
Will there be anything in the case of hostel?
If the hostel says yes, then
will there be anything?
No, no, in the case of hostel yes,
Now show the online payment.
Karunjali online.
Then how will this come?
10,000
I don't know what is coming.
There are charges, bank charges.
These are the charges of Razor Bay.
This is Razor Bay's gateway.
It looks like GST.
Then there is that bifurcation.
Sir, the 10,000
amount is charged.
18% GST and
some amount. I don't know if it is exact.
I will show you.
What are these charges?
These are the charges of the payment gateway
of the bank.
Isn't it more than 10,000?
One minute, I will check.
We don't have any charges on it.
That's what I was asking.
Sir,
please tell us once.
So ma'am,
the charges you are taking from Razor Bay
at what rate, what will it take?
Please share it with me.
I will share the details. Actually I don't have it.
I got it from Razor Bay.
I will share the details with you.
This is a test.
We will also try to make it competitive.
Yes, I will show you
how it is.
We will discuss it.
Because it is about the gateway.
Otherwise, our bank has its own gateway.
Otherwise, we will do it
with our own gateway.
No problem. We will discuss it.
I will call you.
I will discuss it with the ones
Yes, ma'am.
I will tell you all your charges.
Whatever you want.
Yes, I will tell you.
It shows like this.
Scan it and put it on this.
The test mode is coming up.
UPI.
Anjali will not scan it now.
After scanning it,
she goes to the payment
and gets the payment.
Because it will be scanned now.
After scanning the amount,
the amount is deducted.
After that, it is redirected.
How will you show
the test receipt
that you must have made?
What you are saying is
after taking 10,000
you will get a form for the fee
registration. How does it look?
How will the transaction be?
How will the show
be in the registration receipt?
It will be in dummy.
Yes, I will show it in dummy.
Not this, sir.
Not this, Anjali. Go to admission.
Admission data.
Go to application data.
Ma'am, won't it be checked with one rupee?
Sir, it is fixed.
It won't be checked with one rupee.
It was fixed on the amount.
It won't be edited.
Okay.
Sir, don't fix it.
I am saying
why we have fixed it
on 10,000.
There should be a variation.
Okay.
Don't skip. Anjali, you have to pay.
Pay it. Save.
It will be saved like this.
Sir, this type of receipt is broken.
The same receipt will come.
Cancel the receipt.
Cancel.
Show it in the transaction
which is cut by the student.
It will show in the admission transaction.
Not here. Not here.
Open the application in admission.
Here is the transaction.
Sir, the transaction will come here.
Don't print it.
It will come like this.
Our logo is not being displayed.
Ma'am, I want to see it.
Share it in the group.
Because you had formed it.
The information about the form
doesn't come to everyone.
Your documents go to one place.
Sir, look at the receipt
for the fee.
We have to make some changes.
Sir, cash is being written.
We were doing it online.
Sir, if you do it online,
it will be written online.
Okay.
This is the receipt number.
Your admission number will be automatically
recorded.
One minute.
Sir, when this receipt
comes, we will fetch it.
After that, the admission number will be created.
Yes, the admission number
will come after that.
This is going to be a token.
Yes.
In this, payment mode is seen.
Instrument number.
Date is done.
Sir,
student name is done.
Okay.
the form number
will be written
on the application.
Even the application will be
printed.
When this is done,
it will be shown in the account.
Yes, it will be shown in the account.
The registration form
will also be shown?
Yes, it can be done. Cancel it.
Okay.
Ram sir.
Yes, sir.
Is it okay?
No, it is okay.
I just wanted to test it online.
As soon as they
make the payment,
they say that it is not in the modules.
We had to do it live and see
if the payment
is coming on the email or not.
Okay, you are saying that
you have to test it on the email.
Look, ma'am.
Suppose,
as soon as the account
makes the payment,
this receipt
should be in the
email ID mentioned.
If we have it,
we should not give it.
But the receipt should be transferred
to the student's account.
Yes, in the student's email.
Yes, sir.
It should be in the student's email.
What do you want?
Recipts should also be transferred to the student's email?
Yes.
Yes, we are getting it.
Okay, you are saying that
the receipt should also be transferred to the student's email.
Sir, the form will be there.
It will also be written that the student has paid.
The actual receipt
has to be collected from the account
for confirmation.
It cannot be transferred to the student's email.
Sir, it can be risky.
By chance, the student has a refund later.
Think about it.
Sometimes it happens that
the bank has taken the money
but within 3 days, it is not confirmed
for some reason
and the refund is being transferred to the student's email.
No, the refund
means that the amount is back.
Yes, it happens.
What is the problem with that?
It gets cancelled.
For example, the student
has paid the amount.
You are getting the receipt
and the receipt should not be transferred
Ma'am, the student has paid
and by chance,
if the student back the money
then our regular receipts
are also paid back.
That is a part of
accounts.
It is not a problem.
I will discuss this
once.
The receipt is going to the student's email.
You are saying that the receipt
that the student has paid
should be transferred to the form.
The receipt should be transferred
and if it gets cancelled
then it is a different matter.
It should be transferred.
I will discuss this once.
The receipt is going to the student's email
but the receipt is not transferred to the form.
We are there
but if we have to hand over the manual
then we are not online.
We are offline.
Yes, I understood.
The receipt should also be transferred.
Ma'am, we have
told the team
that
we are having a
continuous discussion
that after the registration form
when the student will fill
and he has paid
then two things will be processed
on his email.
The first is the receipt
and the second is the prospectus.
This will be transferred
to the student's email.
That's it.
Ma'am, please do the testing.
After this, I will have them live
with our admission team.
Okay, sir.
And the payment gateway charges
are also there.
Yes, because
we don't have such charges
on our portal yet.
If you fill the online form
then it is only 10,000.
Yes.
Okay.
It's just a copy of the application form.
There's nothing else after that.
But they haven't even paid for it yet.
How will they see it from there?
Kajish ma'am, should I scan it from the GP?
Just scan it with a scanner like this.
I haven't done anything with that.
Scan it from the GP.
There's a testing one. Maybe it's not happening.
It's not happening.
Can't pay with the QR code.
Yes, the testing one is coming.
It's out of time.
Do an over-the-counter.
That will go with the form.
Ma'am, do a change in this.
The restriction that you have imposed 10,000 times.
Do it manually.
Do whatever you want.
Then you can impose restrictions later.
Okay.
Actually, we are waiting for you.
Like this page is available,
we will handover it to the marketing team very soon.
Anjali, go to the form.
Leave it.
Back it.
Yes, do it.
Cancel it.
We will do that later.
Okay, sir.
Tell me one more thing.
I will give you the amount.
First, I will give you the confirmation
of how to do the amount.
Because they are taking the payment gateway charges.
Okay.
Basically, I have to work on the form.
You will share the student data.
That will be imported.
And you have to send me a transport card.
Done.
Okay, sir. Tell me more.
I will share this with you.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Anjali.
They don't show the Zoho form.
You were showing the Zoho form.
Let's not show the Zoho form.
One minute.